hey
do you guys get emails from a nigerian
prince
i get text messages but they're all in
your spam folders oh
maybe oh yeah it's going to the wrong
there's so many spam text messages
but they they need help and do you guys
ever try to help him out
i reply with like go [ __ ] yourself or
sometimes you talk to royalty that way
i know they're not my royalty oh no true
sure probably richer than them they need
my money
they think i have millions but yeah if
you guys don't know what
the the nigerian prince friend we're
talking about is
uh it's a well-known fact that uh
people do get these spam emails asking
for
money and asking for help and just
trying to buy anything on craigslist and
you'll get an email from one of them
true and a lot of times what they do is
oh i can't i've because of political
turmoil or
a natural disaster in my country i can't
do certain things but i need your help
mr samara good samaritan and then they
ask you for your bank account and all
that stuff and they're like if you just
send me a wire of one thousand dollars
i'll send you five million
yes exactly they make it convincing
though they're like basically you have
to send a thousand so we can confirm
that it's a real account
yeah but you could do it with one cent
exactly
i like watching the scam videos that
they get them they're like hey it's not
going through can you send me like 50
and then they actually do and then
they're like i'm [ __ ] these guys get
pissed
that's so dumb yeah it's shady but
when i talk about those guys asking for
a thousand dollars
that is small time compared to what
these nigerian princes
are doing and when i say prince they
like kings dude yeah they're more like
kings these are real princesses
are they nigerian they are nigerian
they're not prince they're not royalty
whatsoever
they're actually instagrammers oh
they have bought themselves lambos
rolls royces they just publicly put it
out there like i scan people
no they they got caught oh they say
they're real estate developers
mm-hmm nigerian real estate developers
they're
[ __ ] ballin dude i actually gave this
story to uh uh casey
but if you if you send out a thousand
emails you're gonna get one or two
that's gonna
fall for it how do you sleep at night
like this in a soft aspect
he looks like he's feeling really
comfortable yeah specifically you how
are you sleeping
how do you sleep i want to sleep at like
maybe six i don't care about you
i was just saying it was a [ __ ]
phrase well i think they could sleep at
night
uh pretty nicely because i think they
can afford some pretty nice beds
but but they also sleep nicely because i
don't think they have a conscience of
uh of ruining people per se what they go
after is they go after companies
oh so what they do is i'm not too sure
how they do this first step
but what i'm reading is that they uh
they monitor
uh how a certain company interacts with
their customers
through email chains and whatnot and
they basically
enter the conversation redirect the
email
make an email that looks like the
original email and then redirect their
conversation towards
between them and the customer and out
the company
and basically take over this trend this
business transaction
wait so it's with the customer or with
the still with the customer with the
customer
oh it's not that's still a purpose but
with the customer the customers
is another business though that's the
thing so but they they oh it's with
business to business
yeah this is the business yeah so
they're they're they're stealing like
millions at a time wow can you teach me
how to do this
yeah right so this guy the one i sent
you was 40 million
but i got confirmation it was actually
450 million
holy moly yeah and then i i cross
referenced
my sources because are you in this [ __ ]
you know some nigerians
no no no so like i went on their
instagram because i wanted to check
right yeah
and my friend was following them yeah at
hush puppy is one of the guys yeah so i
started checking out their 2.5 million
followers wow
they're big and then i was like wait my
friends following them so i dm'd them i
was like do you know this guy
hush puppy oh my god did your friend get
no well my my
so my friend has a picture with him and
um
akon oh econ and they were at a film
festival together he goes yo this guy's
like he was like yeah we were about to
go hang out and he goes and he ended up
giving this motivational speech at my
friend's apartment and he's like he was
teaching us literally everything about
everything wait like everything like how
to scam
or life it was like yeah he was like he
was talking about how he grew up in a
village in nigeria and then like he
started looking for
cracks in the system of businesses oh my
god he just [ __ ] gave all the
information basically yeah and then
they're just
no wonder he got caught he was very open
with his information
but i mean the guys that he was telling
to are extremely wealthy
so like they don't i don't think they
care either yeah i probably did some
[ __ ] to get there
that's true well the guy that i know
it's family wealth but then
i was like are you [ __ ] kidding me
right so he has a picture with one of
these
guys in akon they're hanging out
together and i'm like
what it makes sense that they hang out
together because money hangs out with
money like i get it
not like hanging out they were just
hanging out at a festival together like
in a like kind of like a like taking a
picture or you mean like a big group
yeah
yeah yeah yeah like walt kicks it with
wealth yeah but they just met like they
don't they're not
that tight yeah yeah that makes sense
but it was wild though i was like
okay well to me well i'm not really a
you know
big on people getting scammed and crying
but okay just think about a village boy
who's in a very impoverished country and
he finds his way
to make 400 million dollars by
finding holes in different cracks like
okay
you can't say what a bad guy or whatever
but how's that any different
from big corporations exploiting
african natural resources they go to
these countries and then they do that
there's no difference
right it's the same [ __ ] they're all
horrible it's all [ __ ] up
but you know for me sometimes i just
have this robin hood
feeling inside of me and i'm just like
man you came from
a really [ __ ] up situation and i'm not
trying to glorify this but hey you found
a way i mean you're in jail now because
you're paying for the crimes but
true that's the risk you put you did you
did the risk but you found a way
yeah it's with that it's like it's much
different from like a drug cartel he's
killing all these people oh yeah that's
true
that's it's kind of like a violent no
violence crying it's a non-violent
i mean they're still all [ __ ]
horrible and i know that's exactly what
you're saying i know that's what you're
saying
big pharma is way worse than these guys
that's what i'm saying but no one looks
at them and says hey how many
americans are dying every [ __ ] year
from your drugs yeah that's true
it's helping us not killing us yeah but
then it's like um
i'd rather educate the people so they
don't get scammed but the people that
fall through the cracks and do get
scammed that's their fault
yeah that's crazy but yeah these guys
they um they got
uh they got picked up in dubai they were
basically living at large
in dubai um you say 400 million 400
million cash is confiscated 13 luxury
cars consisting of lambos
can you imagine 400 million cash i can
imagine that what does that look like
what if it's like what if it's like a
box you know how like in real life it's
not that big
it's in here bro well a million in like
hundreds is this
really yeah so 400 of those oh that's
pretty big of that big that's like
you need a pretty good car how many ten
thousand are in a million
ten thousands are in a million a hundred
thousand
no no no no no ten thousand wait what my
problem's not working
a bundle of a hundred is ten thousand
dollars a thousand
yeah this right here would be in a bank
it's it's ten grand
yeah yeah yeah so there'd be how many a
thousand thousand of those oh
a little bit bigger than your pot along
with the confiscation they got
uh 21 computers they picked up 21
computers and 47
smartphones with addresses of nearly 2
million
victims 2 million victims i feel like
when you scam there should be a point
where you're like i have enough money to
stop before getting caught
maybe they like the thrill they have to
they're like a dick they're addicted to
it yeah
and then they get the post about it and
like show off their their wealth
i think you also want to enter different
leagues so i think first you break the
seven figure mark you know oh these are
the people i'm hanging with
and then you can break the eight figure
mark and they're like oh cool so i could
fly first class whenever
i want and then you go wait but those
fools have their own planes
do you want to break the nine figure
mark i'm gonna hang out with the planes
and you wanna i wanna
own a plane so i think you just try to
enter a different league you're never
satisfied i just wanna unlock
new toys and think about it you got a
picture with akon i could get a picture
with eight cars you gotta pay like 200
bucks for the vip pass
but it's not the same because you're
like it's different when you're hanging
out
and you're just like what's up elon
how's it going my man i saw the missile
launch and you go
hey car what's up and you get a [ __ ]
selfie and that's more natural than like
mister how about it can i get a picture
yeah i could photoshop dude hell yeah
you do a great job
great when you met joe rogan that was
awesome yeah but like it's not the same
it's not you're living a lie i'll do the
opposite take a picture
with like snoop dogg and photoshop a
regular person on there
i'm i'm not you heard right i'm in a
picture of someone you change his face
and it's nadeem and i put some regular
there or you just take a picture with
them but then you crop them out whether
you tell us them
yeah yeah you crop out the rock
dude that'd be so tight to meet all
kinds of celebrities and you're like
oh my god denzel do you mind taking a
picture of me and my wife and then like
he takes it
probably go viral for doing that you can
do that a lot of people i'll be a tight
troll move
hey the rock can you take a picture of
me and my wife or just picture taken by
them so you give them the phone to take
a picture of you
that's what it just says oh that's what
you just said yeah
like you're the rock can i give you the
phone oh
he was enjoying his joke first i was
still in my head of coming up with that
that's so funny great minds great minds
we got we're on the same page
hey but the their instagram is pretty
insane though
they look like some prince [ __ ] i want
to follow this [ __ ] because this [ __ ]
looks so tough i wonder if he's still
posting
no more posts i don't know if he could
post in jail what do they do with those
cards do they take them to police
auction i want an auction for one i do
have those my brother got it one of his
first cars at a police auction
and it's like drug dealer cars like this
yes i wonder if it was the dubai police
or like i don't know they said interpol
or something
oh that's that makes sense international
that's [ __ ]
seven dude oh double of 700 uh arrested
yeah he came out like little
he repelled from the ceiling
this is what they got me doing though
but yeah they're uh
they're being extradited to the us and
they're being charged in
chicago court uh for wire fraud and
laundering hundreds of millions of
dollars of
cyber crime so i guess uh certain
companies
are in chicago from chicago yeah the
companies that they want to watch a
movie on this [ __ ]
me too this is definitely movie worthy
yeah and then just stick to
james bond suppose we followed them from
their childhood yeah
oh yeah damn dude that's crazy
that's wild i mean think about it like
450 mil
right like i can't even think about that
much i can't like that's a
major company here but only just for two
people though it makes me smile when i
think about it
well he probably has a team if he if
they stole like 20
computers true he has like a home he has
a company one's loading he too those
companies like
get their money back through before this
like through insurance or like
for the bank that we got scammed or not
yeah
under the money yeah how does that
happen who keeps the money with my money
gets stolen
i get it back within like an hour so it
was fog or something weren't they
missing like
some billions of dollars through uh all
the
other wells fargo yeah oh no also i was
thinking about like
with the whole corona stimulus like it
was going to scammers
like billions of dollars what i was
going to dead people
people were doing identity theft and
they were signing up
and going to scammers and dead people so
great yeah well they sent out to
everyone's [ __ ] um
uh like address so you just went through
the mail and picked up hella checks well
one of the scams they were doing is they
would call
you and then they'll be like oh i'm
trying to send you this check and then
they get your information
and then what they wire some [ __ ] around
and then
they just deposit into their account
using your information what i hate right
now is i have something in uh
debt collection so every time i call to
get it like fix or pay for it
it's not like 100 bucks right but it's
um it's a
indian person right which is fine but
they give me the fakest name and they
tell me where the thing so i know
so we just immediately think of a scam
uh if some guy was like hey my name is
charles green but they have like
the thickest indian accent and then i
call back it's another indian person
with the widest name ever that's what
i'm like okay this is obviously fake
hi my name is bart simpson so i'm like
i'm like [ __ ] clinton
they're legit i still can't believe it
you're like
yeah right lisa simpson yeah
[Music]
you